okay so this one is going to be tough
for me getting slightly personal here i
have a phobia of snakes the way they
move look feel eat everything about them
just scares me which is probably why
i've been avoiding making a reichardt
video but i'm going to suck it up grab
my serpent hunter sword and beat the
lore right out of this weird snake also
make sure to subscribe my dog joy gets
tummy rubs every time someone new
subscribes to the channel so she and i
appreciate it if you do so with all that
said let's talk about pride of riker the
lord of blasphemy
first thing i need to explain that will
help us identify family relationships
between the demi-god children is that
they mainly show us through hair color
if they're a child of america and
godfrey then they'll have white or
blonde hair just like with morgot godwin
and godric we don't know moog's hair but
we can assume it would be blonde
underneath his horns if they're a child
of ratagon and ranala then they'll have
red hair like radon ronnie and reichard
make it hard to identify their hair
colors since ronnie is a doll and
reichardt is now the face on the side of
a god devouring snake if we look at
ronnie's body at the top of the carrion
divine tower we can see traces of red on
the top of her head so we can assume she
did have red hair along with reichardt
then finally if you're children of
ratagon in america you'll either get red
or blonde hair like melania and mykola
this is because ratagon and america are
both the same person and have somehow
popped out two kids with horrible birth
defects but at least they get some cool
hair colors i'm explaining all of this
because i want you guys to look at
something the opening cut scene shows us
still images of what transpired before
and shortly after the night of black
knives and the shattering of the elden
ring now we've all seen this image of
what we originally thought was reichardt
being devoured by the smaller version of
the god devouring snake but if you look
closely this isn't reichard this person
has whitish blonde hair whereas we can
guess just based on family genes that
reichardt would most certainly have red
hair so the person in this image isn't
reichard but is more than likely godwin
the golden this is likely one of the
first gods that the serpent devoured
since god when at this point was just a
lifeless body after his soul was killed
during the night of black knives let's
read the description of the remembrance
of the blasphemous we receive after
killing reichardt reichardt took the
form of a giant serpent that he might
devour grow and live eternally quoting i
understand the road of blasphemy is long
and perilous one cannot walk it
unprepared to sin so what we can gather
from this is that this god devouring
snake is eating growing and likely
shedding its skin constantly we can see
the snake shedding off some dead skin in
the opening cutscene image and we can
find an even larger husk of shedded skin
in the godskin noble boss room near
volcano manor after consuming godwin the
snake grew large enough to shed its skin
even further and the husk of godwin's
face this is why we see godwin's
flattened face at two different
locations
underneath stormville castle and the
deep root depths it's likely the shedded
skin of godwin's face off of the god
devouring serpent this would likely
explain why there's this scaly body form
under the husk in the deep root depths
and why his face is so large in these
areas obviously much larger than normal
let's read the item description of the
blasphemous claw a slab of rock
engrained with traces of the rune of
death on the night of the dire plot
ronnie rewarded prey to reichard with
these traces should the coming trespass
one day transpire they should serve as a
last respite foil allowing reichardt to
challenge malachet the black blade the
black beast of destined death so
reichard did something so important in
the night of black knives that ronnie
felt inclined to reward him ronnie
needed someone to be sacrificed for her
ritual to kill her empyrean flesh and no
longer have to answer to the two fingers
or the golden order for this to happen
ronnie must kill her body while another
must kill their soul riker must have
helped ronnie and the black knight
assassins capture godwin in order to
complete this ritual reichard went along
with this plan so he could feed godwin
to gain power for the god devouring
serpent if we think back to reichard's
remembrance he was ready to commit a sin
he was ready to be the face of the
entire plot ronnie likely didn't want
anyone to know it was really her plan so
reichardt took the fall for his sister
and became known as the lord of
blasphemy if you think about all the
other demigods and their followers they
all follow their leader without any
hesitation radon melania even moog all
have their loyal followers whereas
reichard's followers would drop him at
the first chance they get hell they want
you to kill reichard i left the serpent
slaying spear in the lord's chamber
worthy tarnished
brandish the spear and run him through
well they want you to try and kill him
it's mainly a ploy to send strong
warriors to battle against reichard and
likely be devoured to make him even more
powerful that's sort of the entire point
of the volcano manor it's basically a
trap house they entice tarnished
warriors like us whether it's making us
feel welcomed through invitation from
other members or through its objective
challenge we are tarnished after all we
want reichard's great rune and most
characters in the lands between know
this about the tarnished that's our
entire purpose at least from the start
we need the great runes in order to mend
the elden ring back together so it's our
duty to kill rykerd in order to receive
his great rune they only want the strong
to join the volcano manor so they
display this challenge on the road into
the manor they hang and display bodies
in order to scare away those who wish to
attack the manor and entice strong
warriors to join them with the tarnish
they choose not to kill they use them to
hunt down and kill their own kind this
makes us stronger and essentially a
better meal to eventually feed to the
serpent so just know that the volcano
manor is trying to play you no matter
what you choose they're confident that
you can't kill reichardt however it does
seem like some of his followers just
stick around just to have a chance to
obtain his power after we do defeat
reichard we can see tana trying to
consume riker's head oh
you
allow me some time
our lord's carcass is vast
and not easily consumed
dear reichard
please
find purchase within me
i wish to be your serpent
your family
one day
let us devour the gods together so it's
really not like riker was a good guy for
taking the fall for his sister it seemed
like he was ready to be known as the bad
guy from the very start of their plan he
wanted to seek more power so he could
feed himself to the serpent great rune
and all as it says in the description of
his great rune ronnie and reichard were
ready to discard their great runes and
go down their own paths for the power
that they wanted they orchestrated this
plan and started the events of mistrust
with the golden order driving queen
america to the brink and eventually the
shattering of the elden ring reichardt's
story really isn't a good one but at
least he wanted to help his sister in
one way or another even if it was
ultimately for his own gain but like we
talked about he really didn't seem to
care he was truly ready to leave
everything he knew in order to seek his
own power which led him down this lord
to blasphemy and eventually everyone
seen him as nothing more than a
disgusting power hungry monster last
thing i'll leave you with is the item
description of one of my favorite
weapons in the game the blasphemous
played sacred sword of reichard lord of
blasphemy remains of the countless
heroes he has devoured rife upon the
surface of this blade now they share the
same blood bound together as family
hmm
thank you all for watching the video i
hope you enjoyed it and let me know what
you'd like to see next the support on
this channel has been absolutely insane
recently so just know i appreciate every
single one of you make sure to subscribe
if you want to and i'll see you all in
the next one take care
[Music]